you've done a lot of topics in
mathematics many many topics and
sometimes it's very obvious when they're
related together but other times it
feels like oh you know today is just a
trigonometry day and then the next week
it's like oh it's a statistics day and
it's just a piece of nothing to do with
each other okay now I would like in the
topics of mathematics kind of like
understanding the different systems
there are in a human body okay now
obviously you can study them in
isolation obviously and that's how we
have experts people who are like
cardiovascular surgeons or people who
sort of specialize in the respiratory
system or the nervous system or the
digestive system or the I'm don't know I
don't do biology some running outta
systems here okay by my point is even
those of you who didn't do biology like
me no because you wouldn't have at one
of these things that it's sort of a bit
silly in the end to study a system like
the cardiovascular system in isolation I
mean for instance it's pretty obvious if
you even look at the shape of the
cardiovascular system it's in two halves
and the reason it's in two halves it
because because it has a particular
relationship with the respiratory system
right one of the two halves doing one
part one half is delivering oxygen and
the other half is taking away the waste
products right so it's like well how far
can you understand the cardiovascular
system if you don't know anything about
the respiratory system ok now it's the
same in mathematics we're doing complex
numbers right now okay but importantly
there are two main other systems if you
like their complex numbers interact with
you may want to drop these down I'll
drop in them the first one which I'm
going to this is what this is about the
first system or topic that were you
going to interact with it is tree and
the second one which you've already
tasted a little bit off but there's more
to come is polynomials okay now right
now what we're going to do is we're just
going to focus on the complex numbers
parts of this system
well it's like look okay yes we know the
rotisserie system has an impact obvious
but you don't need to know everything
about their spiritual system to
understand and cardiovascular in the
same way I'm just going to tell you the
little bits of this that will help you
that will equip you to understand the
bits in complex numbers with a touch ok
so now that's not the way I really need
to find a little i firstly if you had it
already the heading I'd like you to make
is radiant measure now Radian measure is
the name of a topic you will encounter
next year maybe some of you have heard
it already I'm only going to tell you a
very small part of Radian measure the
part that relates to complex numbers ok
and expect the next year sometime one
and two you will find out a whole lot
more if you'd be like oh this rings a
bell so let me tell you pierce central
number one radians radians what are they
radians for our intents and purposes you
need to understand them as an
alternative way to measure angles okay
down alternative way to measure angles
now you might think her what's wrong
with degrees and the answer is actually
there are lots of things wrong with
degrees and you'll find out when you do
Radian measure proper but for now I want
you to understand when you read like the
angles that we going to talk about today
we're going to do all of them in radians
okay you may momentarily think 0 degrees
you'll need to convert a little bit and
you'll get more comfortable with that as
time passed and now because you're
probably not comfortable yet we need to
know some common quantities so when you
see a number or a particular kind of
angry like I know that is in radians
okay so the most important when you want
to start with is a revolution a full
revolution rather than saying it's 360
degrees to turn all the way around we
would say in radians that's 2 pi radians
yes pi as in the circle number pine
right so for revolution all
round is two pi radians what we're
straight angle half a revolution babe
it's just going to be that's a terrible
writing it's just gonna be PI right so
pi radians will take you half way around
the circle soup Iranians will take you
all the way what do you think might be
one common sense final common quantity
to include on there a right angle right
so normally your ten ninety degrees but
you can see I've got these in Odyssey
you can see it a little more obviously a
right angle is just half of a straight
angle yes so in radians i would say pie
on two that's all you need to know about
radians today like I said there's a hot
water this topic you're like woof what
kind of a topic is this okay well
there's plenty more to come but for now
I just need you to have this idea in
your head because we're going to talk
about angles today and we're going to
talk in terms of radians dilip degrees
okay